I think it's going to surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
it's going to be different from any
superhero movie ever made
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
than james gunn i was excited with an
opportunity
to be able to do the suicide squad in
the way it could be done from my point
of view
this one is completely unique this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters in comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy of characters within each of our
characters there's a certain beauty
within most of them some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
be like a d*uchey captain america the
guy who believes
in peace at any cost no matter how many
people he needs to
kill along the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone's exploding heads arms
legs
it's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life this is by far the
biggest movie i've ever made
i don't think that you know what to
expect
don't get too attached this has been
truly
the greatest most exciting
journey of my life making this film
cut that was great
you know the deal
successfully complete the mission you
get 10 years off your sentence
welcome to task force x these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few days
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the suicide
squad trailer that they dropped at dc
fandom this weekend we found out who all
the characters are playing we got a
bunch of footage there's a bunch of
easter eggs so i'll explain where this
fits in the justice league dceu
continuity
and how this relates to the first
suicide squad movie there were a bunch
of other trailers that dropped this
weekend i'm doing videos for everything
so be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos i'm also doing a giveaway for
this giant
box of dc fandom merch that they sent me
so all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber let me know
which new super weird suicide squad
character is your favorite
the way they explain this movie is that
it's sort of a soft reboot of the
franchise without completely retconning
the events of the first
film but it does take place after the
events of the first film it also takes
place after the events of justice league
obviously the justice league snyder cut
doesn't really change the timeline that
much it still takes place
relative to where the other films take
place but it also takes place after the
events of the birds of prey movie even
though it doesn't necessarily reference
a lot of stuff in that movie
most of what you see from harley quinn
will just reference her history with the
joker even though james gunn did say
that jared leto's joker does not appear
during this movie they obviously have to
reference each of the characters
backstories in some quick hilarious way
so when they're referencing harley
quinn's backstory they'll just reference
the events of the previous film
briefly her history with the joker and
her history with ben affleck's batman in
gotham but also ben affleck's batman
does not appear during this movie either
even though he's coming back for the
flash movie i'll do a separate video for
the flash movie teaser because they just
revealed a whole bunch of big stuff
about that film
the way they're describing this film
though is that it's a gritty 1970s war
movie as they say during the trailer the
cool thing about that
is that matt reeves just said that the
batman movie with robert pattinson is
based on gritty 1970s cop shows in the
movie chinatown
and joaquin phoenix's joker movie is
also based on that same gritty 1970s
aesthetic
so all these crazy dc movies seem like
they're going heavy on the 1970s just in
terms of style so if you really like
that aesthetic
a lot of these films are going to feel
like that too but just to be clear the
batman movie with matt reeves is an
exception to the continuity it's not
really connected to justice league or
the suicide squad movie
that exists in its own separate
continuity i've already done a video
about that trailer so i'll add a link
for that at the end of this and in the
description because it was badass
but this new version of the suicide
squad gets caught up in a foreign war
they didn't say where the war is
happening but from all the footage it
just seems like it's somewhere generally
in the south american region
probably going to be some big location
from dc comics history
some of the bigger surprises though are
peter capaldi playing the thinker
obviously there was a version of that on
the flash tv show but peter capaldi's
version is a much more comic book
accurate version like you can actually
see the nodes
sticking out of his skull that they have
for his prosthetics
really happy to see this version of king
shark i have a really big theory about
how they're going to pull that off
in taiwan td's quote-unquote mystery
character nobody guessed who idris elba
was playing
in michael rooker too big surprises so
i'll explain all the characters with
some of the bigger justice league dceu
easter eggs that connect this to the
other movies
but the premise of the movie is simple
there's a foreign war that amanda waller
is forced to deal with so she sends in
the suicide squad to handle it
now during the footage you see them
rescuing little girls but it also seems
like they're trying to topple a dictator
in a foreign government
which is a very suicide squad thing to
do they don't do a lot of large-scale
assaults on foreign countries
they're more of a surgical group that
amanda waller sends in to topple
foreign dictators when she wants to get
rid of them when they become an
inconvenience to the united states or
the organization
for the price of 10 years off their
sentence they complete the mission as
she says you get 10 years off your
sentence which is also a bit of a teaser
for sequels if this movie does well
enough
which it seems like it will it seems
like it's going to be the biggest
craziest movie ever
but some of these characters for
instance have done things that are so
terrible that they probably have
consecutive life sentences on their
terms
so getting 10 years knocked off doesn't
really help them that much
so they'd have to go on a ton of
different missions in order to
meaningfully reduce their sentence
but the funny thing about this the whole
tagline of the movie don't get too
attached quote unquote it's just to let
you know that they're definitely going
to kill off some of these really
ridiculous characters
i'm looking at you nathan fillion and
flula so if you feel like some of the
characters costume just make them feel
super crazy and silly it's probably
because they're going to kill them off
in hilarious ways during the movie
for instance nathan fillion is playing a
character called tdk
that is not a character from dc comics
history but early theory
tdk the initials stand for the
detachable
kid as in a version of arm's fall-off
boy which was an early theory people had
about his characters
but early predictions he's going to be
one of the earliest characters that they
kill off in some hilarious way
i also love that they're doing king
shark so big and crazy he almost seems
like he's going to be a version of king
shark from the harley quinn animated
series
the more comedic version because get
this yes you do see him running through
the trailer just eating people
left and right anything he can get his
fins on but steve agee is the one doing
the motion capture for him running
around on set like you see him in that
giant harness
but the theory is is that taika watiti
who's listed prominently in the credits
but doesn't appear during the trailer
is just doing voiceover for a character
he's probably going to do the voiceover
for king shark
so king shark will just run around in
the film sounding like a kiwi
while eating people left and right think
about king shark just running around
sounding like korg in the movie they
also finally confirmed that sean gunn is
doing a version of the weasel character
from the comics this is what he looks
like in the movie like really really
horrific but it's probably gonna be kind
of hilarious too
it's funny to see him going from playing
rocket tiny raccoon
motion capture on the set of the
avengers films and guardians of the
galaxy
to also playing a larger rodent-like
character
but i don't know if he's also going to
do the voice of the weasel character 2
or if they got somebody else to do that
i love how john cena is saying that his
peacemaker character is like the
d*uchiest version of captain america you
could possibly imagine
and that's how he played him during the
movie idris elba's character actually
has a bit of a cool backstory that ties
into some of the justice league and the
superman movies
so he's playing bloodsport nobody
guessed that but in the dc eu
he's been imprisoned for shooting henry
cavill's superman with a kryptonite
bullet so obviously this takes place
after the events of justice league when
superman has come back to life
but because he's a mercenary he was
hired by jesse eisenberg's
lex luthor so just a little bit of extra
superman story going on in the
background
i don't know if that means that henry
cavill is going to cameo during the film
because there were a lot of rumors about
him signing a new contract to show up in
a couple different dc movies
there's a way that they could do that
superman scene of him shooting with the
kryptonite bullet without actually
having to have henry cavill on screen
you could just have him off in the
distance being shot with a kryptonite
bullet
but it would be way cooler just to have
him on screen for like two
seconds while they do that backstory
scene i'm really interested to see how
they explain
mon gao because she's the daughter of
mongol in the dceu so we know that he
exists out there somewhere even though
we haven't seen him on screen
there's a lot of space-based dc movies
like the green lantern corps that we
just haven't got to yet where we would
see those characters
so hopefully at some point they'll get
around to making that new green lantern
core movie or maybe they'll show up
during the hbo series and they can do
war world during that
harley quinn has a couple new badass
costumes she's going to be crazy as always
you've seen so much of margot robbie's
harley quinn that i feel like you kind
of know what you're going to get
going into one of her movies you all
know about captain boomerang joel
kinnaman's rick flack amanda waller
all them coming from the events of the
first film david dostmotion is playing
polka dot man obviously one of the more
ridiculous characters cannot wait to see
what he's like during the movie
michael rooker looking crazy with that
white wig is the savant character i
actually thought that pete davison was
playing savant but he's just another
character who's really good with
hand-to-hand combat so just expect
michael rooker to be super crazy
you all probably know flula from either
his youtube channel or the other comedic
stuff that he's been doing recently in
the movies but his javelin character is
actually from the booster gold comics
there was a booster gold movie that they
were going to try and make at some point
that was going to be a comedy i don't
know what happened to that maybe we'll
see him show up somewhere
but let me know in the comments which of
these new characters are you most
excited about obviously that's not all
the brand new characters that are going
to be in the film there'll be a bunch of
easter eggs but the way james gunn talks
about it it's going to be huge and crazy
and nobody has guessed the plot
completely
the movie's coming out in august next
year around this time so we probably
won't see the next
really big trailer until sometime early
next year
but if they drop any more footage or
promos or anything like that of course
i'll do a video
there will be more trailers for the
justice league snyder cut i'm still
doing a video for the flash movie teaser
for the black adam movie teaser and i've
already done a video about the batman
trailer so you can click here to watch
that a billion more times
and click here for all the other dc
fandom movie trailers
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!